DMITRIY NOVAKOVSKIY:
Hi, everyone.
Thanks a lot for
joining us tonight--
tonight, in this
afternoon-- and so
hope you all had a good lunch.
So what we'll do today is
we'll do the talk called
"Where should I run my code?"
And the point of this talk
is to pretty much help
you navigate between
various compute options
that we have within
the Google Cloud.
My name is Dmitriy Novakovskiy.
I'm a sales engineer here at
Google Cloud in Amsterdam.
And together with me
on stage later today
will be Freek van de
Griendt from g-company,
our great partner.
So quick disclaimer
at the very beginning.
We will have to defer
questions until the very end
if we have time.
If we don't have time
for the questions,
then we will just stick around
for a couple more minutes,
and you can catch
us and ask whatever
questions that you might have.
We have to be
strict on time here.
So before we start, I want to
ask for a quick raise of hands.
Can you please raise your
hands if you have not
yet used Google Cloud, ever?
OK, that's actually good.
So some of our demos
will be on spot today.
One more time, could you
please raise your hand
if you consider yourself to
be on the software development
side of the house?
And is anyone from
DevOps side of the house?
OK, that's not bad.
Good.
So yeah, as I said,
questions at the very end.
Now what we'll be doing today.
Today we'll do an overview
of four main compute options
in Google Cloud, including
Compute Engine, Container
Engine, App Engine,
and Cloud Functions.
The purpose of each
section is to give you
the sense of what
each service is doing
and when you might want to use
it for your existing workload
or for the workload
that you want
to consider to bring into
Google Cloud at some point.
Also we'll do the
customer case from Tentoo.
Freek will present it.
And at the end,
we will do a recap
so to see whether we answered,
or not, the questions
on where should I
actually run my code.
So there was a
picture about my goal.
Come on, come back.
You can do it.
So again, the goal is to
remove any ambiguity that
might be existing
up until this point,
and show you where to run what
and where to migrate what.
And also, when you might want
to choose certain trade offs
of one service versus another.
Without further ado, Compute
Engine, or virtual machines,
or infrastructure as a service
within the Google Cloud.
Obviously, first of all,
that's virtual machines,
block storage, and networking.
Like in typical infrastructure,
the service framework,
you can request the
virtual machine's YUI.
You can request virtual
machine's YCli clients
via the API.
So all the usual goodness which
is typical for public clouds.
Now a few specific traits, or
characteristics, I would say,
for, specifically,
Compute Engine.
One is the virtual
machines start very fast.
So average start time
is about 35 seconds.
Another one is the
flexibility of configuration.
So within Google Cloud,
you have the selection
of both a set of
pre-built configurations
for virtual machines, including
also high memory, high CPU
ones, and the custom
machine types.
So you can assign
any virtual machine
to any ratio between
the vCPU and RAM
as much as your
configuration requires.
What was recently introduced,
actually, like months ago,
is the configurations
with extended memory,
where now you don't have
the ratio of 6.5 gigabytes
RAM per vCPU,
meaning that, again,
if you need much RAM for
your CPU, you can do that.
Finally, the choice
of vCPU platform.
So across all the regions
of the Google Cloud,
we're on about five generations
of Intel processors,
and Skylake was the one
most recently introduced.
So one of the features
in Google Cloud
right now allows
you to specify when
you create the
virtual machine, which
is the minimum generation
of Intel processors
which you would like to have.
And finally, this
is my favorite one,
is the self-service
migration at no extra cost.
So if right now, there is some
configuration in another cloud
or on a on-premise
virtualization environment
that you are considering
to move to Google Cloud
and test how it works there,
we have the built-in migration
tool link into Google
Cloud at no extra cost,
and which can migrate VMs
from pretty much anywhere.
Now when would Compute
Engine be useful?
So first and obvious
choice for the good fit
is lift and shift
into Google Cloud.
And by lift and
shift, I'm not only
meaning take some
legacy workload
and try to move it in the Cloud
and get very disappointed.
I actually mean
any virtual machine
based configuration
that runs anywhere
on other public clouds, on
house hostings, on anything.
So anything that runs
with full operating system
stack on someone's hypervisor
is a good candidate
to be put into Compute Engine.
Another example is enterprise
workloads, maybe also requiring
licenses, so things
that might be running
on-premises hypervisor,
or things that might
be licensed on per VM basis.
On per core basis, again, good
candidate for Compute Engine.
Operating system kernel and
performance requirements.
So there are many
companies-- there
are many pieces of
software that are developed
with a specific stack in
mind, with a specific set
of dependencies, with a specific
choice of operating system,
it might be FreeBSD, actually.
In such case,
obviously, you would
want to control the whole--
you would want to control the
whole compute host that you're
running it into, and
Compute Engine would easily
allow you to do that.
And finally, network
protocols beyond HTTPS.
So if the application
of a service that you're
putting into Cloud needs
to talk to something
that is not just plain HTTPS
accessible over browser
or kernel, in many cases, the
load balancers and the services
that you will need for
this will be available,
mainly on Compute Engine.
Now what would be
the constraints
if you choose to go
with Compute Engine?
First of all, there is a
certain scale and speed floor.
And it's not like
it's very high,
so 30 seconds per
virtual machine.
But again, if you're going
for a web-scale workload
and you need to be able
to scale up and scale
down very dynamically, it
might become a constraint.
And this might be
the point where
you would start thinking
about containers,
if you are not doing so yet.
So still good to keep in mind.
Another point is self-managing
configurations and updates.
So when you run on virtual
machines on Compute Engine,
Google can afford certain
complexity of management
using managed instance groups,
when Google Cloud will take
care of updating your VMs from
time to time using the updated
VM images.
But still, the degree
of things that you
will have to manage
within the VM
is kind of higher, compared to
even with Docker containers.
And finally, my
favorite argument
is am I making the
most of my VMs?
Now this has been quite
typical for the last,
I would say, seven years, as
containerization and Docker
were growing.
Because what was
happening is that people
were paying quite
significant money
for getting virtual machines,
or even bare metal hosts,
and keeping them underutilized.
This is still
possible when you are
running on Compute Engine or
any other infrastructures,
or as platform, and making
not exactly optimal choice
when you buy VMs and
keep them underutilized.
Luckily, within
Google Cloud, there
is a tool called rightsizing
recommendations, which will
indicate these things for you.
So if you deployed
a bunch of VMs,
and they are stalling
most of the time,
Google Cloud will recommend
you to at least downsize them.
OK, quick demo on
Compute Engine.
Can we please switch
on the laptop?
This is just a very basic
one, just to give you
the sense of how it looks.
I will zoom in a little bit.
So that's Compute Engine,
here on Google Cloud console.
All the products and
services are actually
called through the
menu on the left.
I'm getting the
Compute Engine, and I'm
going to create a
new virtual machine.
So I hit Create Instance.
I decide how I will name it.
Well, let's say it
will be hello next.
I decide where to place it.
So the list that
you see right now
is the list of
availability zones
currently available
at Google Cloud.
So I will do Europe West 1d.
That's Belgium.
Now the configuration.
So I can choose between the
list of predefined types,
like I told you earlier,
with high memory or high CPU.
Or I can hit
Customize, and that's
where all the goodness starts.
So just with easily
dragging and dropping,
I can increase the size of
VM, decrease the size of VM.
And here on the right,
I will be also seeing
how the price estimate
for changes on the way.
The extended memory feature,
which I mentioned earlier.
So if I don't like the
default ratio on memory,
I can do something like
this, 360 gigabytes of RAM,
18 with CPUs.
I wonder what sort of things
I would be doing there.
Yeah.
And finally, the CPU platform.
So as you see, here
in the Europe West 1d,
I have the choice between
Intel Haskell or later,
or Intel Skylake or later.
So let's go with Intel
Skylake, the latest stuff.
And I will get back to the
standard configurations, just
one vCPU.
Then, obviously, I will
choose the boot disk.
So which version system
do I want to start there.
So typical Linux flavors
are available here.
Also there is Windows somewhere
here, yes, 2016, 2012.
And also, you can actually bring
in your own images-- that's
also important to remember--
from existing cloud
or from a custom built pipeline.
So it's not just limited to
what Google offered here.
A few quick checkboxes to
enable some default firewall
rules, like HTTP, HTTPS.
And further on, there
is a menu for doing
a bunch of other things,
like run in startups tips,
for example, to instantiate
the initial configuration
of the virtual machine.
We will not be
doing anything here.
Let's go and hit Create.
So while it's creating, I
will mention one more thing,
is persistent disks.
So each virtual machine,
you can attach up to--
actually, I don't
remember the number--
you can attach multiple
persistent disks to it,
and they will be network backed.
So they will be placed
within Google network,
attached over network,
replicated, encrypted.
Very secure, very
high performance.
Obviously, the bigger disk you
make, the higher throughput
you will get, and
if you will opt
for SSD as well, because that's
the distributed file systems.
That's just how they work.
So let's get back to the demo.
I have my hello next here.
What I can do now is I can just
hit SSH and get to the terminal
of my virtual machine.
So that's the part which
many folks, especially
from development community,
are appreciating,
because Google Cloud UI is built
in a way when you can pretty
much skip any configurations
on your own machine
in order to be able to get
to the VMs and the resources
that you're doing here.
So both a web shell
for SSH, and also what
is called Cloud Console.
OK, so that was a quick
demo on the Compute Engine.
Can we please switch
back to the slides?
Nice.
So now we've got into
Container Engine,
or managed Kubernetes, or
container as a service.
Quick raise of hands, please.
Please raise your hand if
you are working with Docker.
OK, half a room.
And will you please
raise your hands
if you are working with Docker
using some orchestration tools,
like Kubernetes
or Docker's forum.
OK, that's also very good.
So a quick recap on containers
for those who might not
be familiar with Docker.
Containerization and
Docker Containerization,
namely, allows us to virtualize
the workloads on operating
system level, effectively
encapsulating the application
code and these dependencies
into what is called Container,
and at the same time,
allowing different isolated
workloads to share the same
operating system kernel.
What this gives us
is a lot of benefits,
including portability.
So you can run containers
in different clouds
and different Docker hosts.
Also the performance
and the density.
You remember the argument
about am I getting the most out
of my VMs?
When you run with Docker, you
can pack much more workloads
in the same VM and not
care about dependencies
and overlapping wisdom.
And Docker itself
is not hard to use,
especially when you
start practicing
using docs on one machine.
It's quite straightforward.
It's not much harder
than installing packages
on top of a Linux box.
Where the complexity
comes is when
you have 50 plus Docker hosts,
50 just a random number.
That's what I consider to
be uncomfortable for me.
So you'll have to poke every
Docker host individually
and tell them run this
container, expose this port,
connect to this port.
And the whole complexity comes
in when the application becomes
truly distributed and involved
with multiple containers.
So what helps here is the
project called Kubernetes.
So that's an
orchestration platform
for containerized workloads.
Initially inspired
by Google, right now
developed by many companies,
including Google, Red Hat,
and others.
What it allows,
in general, is it
allows the declarative
definition of application.
So we don't care
anymore about servers.
We don't care anymore about
individual containers.
You just describe which
components your application
consists of, how they should
connect to each other, how they
should discover each other.
And Kubernetes will
take care of where
to put these components
within your cluster,
on top of Docker containers,
and also how many
replicas to create.
So how many examples
of my web server
do I need, how many examples
of my database do I need,
and a bunch of other
things, like scale out
or scale in and load balancing.
Another important
point about Kubernetes
is that it's multi-cloud
and is platform agnostic.
So it runs on any
major cloud provider
and also on bare metal.
So what is Container Engine?
It's the managed
Kubernetes offering
on top of Google Cloud.
It automates management,
upgrades, deployment,
scaling of the cluster
around stable version,
and allows you also to use
so-called alpha clusters.
So it pretty much offsets
all the complexity
of managing the cluster
itself, and lets
you focus on the application
and on deploying it.
Along with that, it offers other
benefits of GCP infrastructure,
so global load balancing, very
powerful, multi-zone clusters.
So Kubernetes clusters,
which will span multiple,
will be availability zones
and be highly available.
And also container
registering, container builder.
These are the things that
you will need anyway when you
will be adopting containers.
Now when to use
Container Engine.
So the great fit is obviously
containerized applications,
right of this.
What I would like to say is
that usually teams who want
Kubernetes, they
ask their bosses.
We want Kubernetes.
We want to run in this
particular platform,
or we want to run on
Dockers 4 or more NSM.
So if the team has
already adopted Docker,
they will probably, at certain
scale, need using Kubernetes.
Another example is Micro
Services based architectures.
So again, when one big monolith
of application developed
somewhere into
thousands becomes split
into a lot of small
services, often the amount
of containers that you will
have to run becomes very big,
and you will need an
orchestration platform.
Multi-hybrid Cloud.
As I already
mentioned, Kubernetes
runs on multiple platforms.
And it actually works.
And again, network
protocols beyond HTTPS.
Next section will be
App Engine, and you
will understand why I'm putting
so much emphasis on it so far.
Best fit or constraints.
You can run only
containerized workloads.
So you cannot run virtual
machines with Kubernetes.
Actually, technically,
you can, but it's
outside of scope of this talk.
Services oriented architecture.
That's kind of the opposite
side of Micro Services based
architectures.
So it's not like
you will want to,
you will have to
refactor the application
and split it into
services in order
to be truly efficient
in Kubernetes.
You will not want to put
like old monolith, which
doesn't scale horizontally
on Kubernetes,
and just get more
complexity for yourself.
So the application
has to conform also.
And finally, imminent
CI/CD pipeline,
Continuous Integration,
Continuous Delivery.
If you will start producing
your own containers
and deploying them at scale,
you will need your own practices
of staged deployment,
development, automatic testing,
things like this.
So Kubernetes is-- it's sort
of a prerequisite for it.
And one piece before we get into
Customer Case is App Engine.
So App Engine is what we call
an original Google Cloud.
It started back in 2008, before
we had the rest of the things.
And it's a platform as a
service offering for Google,
which follows the mentality of
code first UX for developers.
So with App Engine,
we used to want,
and we still want,
and we still do it,
let developers focus purely
on code, deploying the code,
and no additional infrastructure
management required around
whatsoever.
The trade off for it is that
App Engine has, obviously,
certain ways of how
the applications have
to be written to be
able to run on it,
and sometimes it
enables some things,
sometimes it may put
additional constraints.
But the code first UX gets
you to the first deployment
in no time, with
no learning curve.
So you have fully managed,
no ops infrastructure,
load balancing, scale, and
everything is taken care of.
And what's important is
the lowest entry barrier
and shortest learning curve.
So Kubernetes is
friendly to developers,
and it gets even more friendly
to developers with time.
But still, like in my experience
and experience of many people,
when you start
learning Kubernetes,
you have to get into this
whole world of Docker
containers, service
discovery, service management,
a lot of load balancing,
its own object
model, which is quite nice and
gets you additional experience.
But if you want to
deploy something faster,
or if you're not interested
in infrastructure at all,
the barrier of entry on
App Engine is much lower.
So App Engine has
multiple runtime options
across two tiers that it
has, Standard and Flex.
What runtime means is what
sort of language environment
can App Engine support for you.
So today, it's multiple
versions of Python,
multiple versions of Java,
multiple versions of Go.
And most importantly, it's .NET,
and also customer runtimes.
Customer runtimes have
been introduced recently
with App Engine Flex.
And what happens is
that App Engine Flex
runs your workloads, not
like standard one, which
uses underlying
Google's infrastructure
work to run your workloads.
But it runs Docker containers
within the virtual machines.
So you see the similarity with
Kubernetes to some extent.
And this also enables
customized runtimes.
So if some language
is not supported
by App Engine at
the moment, this
can be added by you, by
Google, by certain parties.
That's possible.
The coolest, personally,
for me, thing for App Engine
is how the traffic
splitting works.
That's something that I
will show in the demo.
So all the load balancers
available in Google,
in my opinion, are very
cool and very powerful.
But this one, it
just works magic.
So doing A/B test and can shift
in traffic between the versions
is-- literally happens
on the wave of your hand.
And also App Engine also
supports Micro Services
architectures.
So we just talked about
it in Kubernetes section,
that the application is getting
split into smaller parts,
and services talk to each other.
You can also do it in App Engine
in a slightly less flexible
way, because App Engine has
certain restrictions that it
puts on terms of how the
code has to be structured,
how many applications
you can have,
how many services you can
have within an application.
But still, it is possible.
So you don't have to run
monoliths on App Engine.
But if you're running--
if you plan to
develop something new,
If you want to use your PC
and not just HTTP invocation,
probably you will steer
towards Kubernetes.
OK, so when to use App Engine.
Good fit.
Applications that only need
HTTP as request and response.
That's the pattern,
together with stateless
serving applications.
That's a pattern for App Engine.
That's the web face
in applications
that usually don't
need to talk anywhere
but northbound to the
users that come in.
Mobile and web backends.
So many of our
signature customers
running at very
large scale have been
using App Engine to scale
horizontally very fast, very
reliably, and speed up the
development with this, again,
because the runtimes that we
offer are sufficient for it.
Rapidly scaling to high traffic.
What I just mentioned,
especially on App Engine
standard, which runs
on underlying Google
infrastructure, as
I mentioned to you.
The time of scaling
is very fast.
So new instances can be added
almost instantly, even faster
than containers.
What are the constraints?
So let's say I have a web app
or a mobile backend, whatever.
What will I have to
deal with on App Engine?
First of all, if I choose
App Engine Standard, which
scales faster, costs less,
but has more restrictions,
I will have a set of
predefined runtimes,
and I will not have an
option of custom runtimes.
So if my runtime is not
available for App Engine
Standard, I will not
be able to use it.
Or I will have to
change my runtime.
Can't you [INAUDIBLE].
Quite obvious, the same way
how restricted network and file
system access works.
So when you run on
App Engine Standard,
you cannot write into
your file system.
And the only network
connectivity that you can do
is an out bound to the internet.
You cannot talk within Google
Cloud, only with the APIs.
You cannot talk with--
well, it's pretty much
like web face and hosting.
On Flex, it's a
bit more relaxed.
So first of all, obviously,
we have standard Docker
constraints.
So if it cannot be
put into Docker image,
it will not run on
App Engine Flex.
And second, it's not scale to 0.
So App Engine Standard
can do the scale to 0, 3.
When there is no traffic,
it will scale to 1,
or even 0, instances.
Flex cannot do it.
So Flex runs on
virtual machines,
so you will always have to
maintain some sort of capacity.
So if you're
developing something
that you want to keep on the
free tier and on a low traffic,
probably App Engine
Standard is a better choice.
And again, as I
mentioned earlier,
if you're starting
with a new application,
if you have an environment where
dev and ops are working very
closely-- and we'll talk
about it a bit later--
if you don't yet
know how much it
will scale in terms of
amounts of components
and the size of the team, when
choosing between App Engine
and Kubernetes, make
sure that the structure
of projects in each
of the platforms
will allow you to work with it.
Kubernetes will
be very flexible.
It can use multiple
container registries.
You can use multiple namespace
as multiple Google Cloud
projects.
App Engine is more prescriptive.
So you have one
application per project,
multiple services
within the application,
and multiple versions
of the services.
For someone who just wants to
do the code first and knows
the scope of the
development for whatever--
next half a year or 12 months--
it's enabling.
It makes you work faster.
It makes you care less
about things that you
don't want to care about.
If the level of
uncertainty is higher,
it might happen
that it makes sense
to invest in getting
up with Kubernetes.
OK, so quick demo on App Engine.
Can I please switch
to the laptop?
This will be
actually faster even.
OK, so here I have my
App Engine dashboard--
and it failed to load
because I don't have Wi-Fi.
Interesting.
Let's try again.
Oh, I'm not supposed
to have the Wi-Fi.
I am on the wired connection.
Anyways.
So I have the--
just a second, I will still
check the connectivity,
because it seems like I'm
having a bit of trouble here.
OK, so I lose the
wired connection.
I will try to do it
through the Wi-Fi.
I was still wired.
That's not something
that you would expect.
OK, so I have my App
Engine deployment.
And I have two versions
of my application running.
Let's wait for it to show up.
No, no chance.
Yeah, we will not get there.
OK, we'll skip the App Engine
demo because of the networking
part.
Please switch back
to the slides.
Sorry about that.
So before we hand over
to the customer example,
I will tell you the story
of all their App Engine now.
So over there, I
have an application
running in two versions,
which each of them
displays a different version of
the website, a very simple one
like Hello, Next Amsterdam.
So I had to relay
this message to them.
You remember, I
mentioned a load balancer
was a traffic splitter.
So when you run with App Engine,
and you deploy a new version
of a website, or of
application, or whatever--
your ecommerce store--
it's very easy to shift
the traffic in natural way,
like what is the percentage
of the users which
I want to go to
version 1, what is
the percentage of
the users which
I want to go to version 2.
So this both enables
you to easily
deploy, and your actions roll
back to them, and test them,
like do, sort of, A/B
testing between the users.
And that's the user
experience, which
is available right
now, mostly on App
Engine and similar platforms.
Because when you're on
Kubernetes, for example,
you have to scale blue green
in a more involved fashion.
So if the runtimes fit you,
I recommend you try it out.
OK, so I will hand
over to Freek now
to present the customer
example of Tentoo.
[APPLAUSE]
FREEK VAN DE GRIENDT: Mic.
Now it's working.
Thank you.
So I'm Freek van de Griendt.
I'm a director at g-company.
We are a premiere
Google Cloud partner.
And we give trainings on all of
this fancy technology for all
of you developers
and DevOps out there.
We actually have
a booth here where
you can get a discount
on our training,
so please check it out.
It's in the main hall.
But I'm not here today to
pitch you about our training.
I'm here to tell you about a
customer example at Tentoo.
So you've seen the many
examples of really, really
cool technology.
And actually, what I
wanted to show you today
is what you can do with it in
a very, very simple case, which
is Tentoo.
Tentoo is a payrolling company,
active both in the Netherlands
and in Belgium, and they have a
focus on the artistic and event
sector.
Now just to tell you
something about what they do,
is they manage the part time
employment support people.
So working in the
artistic sector
and doing events
like students guiding
the people around here as
typically the activities
that Tentoo does.
Just for your information, they
manage the part time employment
of about 5,000 people on an
annual basis just in Belgium.
And they do this with a
team of 15 people only.
So that's full operations.
So they are one of the
first payrolling companies
that have been
doing this for years
to rely heavily on their
digital platform, which
they call My Tentoo.
So we've engaged with them
since the end of 2015.
And when we first met them,
they had a couple of challenges.
So first of all,
their infrastructure
was completely outdated.
It was a mixture
of six applications
that were all patched
together with old fashioned
integrations.
And worst of all,
these applications
were actually inherited from
the Dutch mother company.
So it was very, very
difficult for Tentoo
to follow with
Belgian legislation.
If you do payrolling in Belgium,
if you know anything about it,
it's quite complicated,
much more complicated
than in the Netherlands.
So it's a big
challenge, let alone
that they could innovate
towards their customers.
So their customers
go in this platform
and create contracts
on a daily basis.
So the more modern,
the more usable
the platform is, the bigger
their competitive advantage,
which they want to increase
over time, obviously.
So Tentoo is a--
I just mentioned it's 15
people, so it's a small company.
It's an SMB.
They don't have any dedicated
IT or network administrators
in-house.
So sometimes they
just were just facing
with the fact that their
internet connectivity went
down, and so customers were
not able to create contracts,
just for a full day,
which obviously, for them,
was a legal
nightmare, because you
have to comply to certain
DIMONA standards, et cetera.
It's all very complicated.
It's bad.
So basically we went
and go and advise them
on how we could solve
this challenge using
Google technology.
And that's what I want
to focus on today.
So we have built for
them a web application.
So it's a modern
web application that
basically works on any device.
We've used the App
Engine for that
because of many of the reasons
that Dmitriy just highlighted.
It's just we didn't
want to have anything
to do with moving servers
or maintaining them,
maintaining versions, whatever.
We just wanted to start coding.
So it's backend/frontend
split, so the backend
is in PHP, which was a
requirement by the Dutch mother
company because they wanted
to have some audibility,
and they have some PHP
in-house knowledge there,
which, for us, was fine.
App Engine was able to run that.
And in the frontend,
we're using Angular, also
Google sponsored technology.
And we chose that, mainly
because of the wide developer
audience there is for Angular.
If you have really hardcore
JavaScript developers,
you can discuss whether it's
the right framework to use.
It was a very, very
usable one for us.
Scalability is super
interesting as well.
The loads on Tentoo's
web application
is pretty much 24/7, a little
bit lower in the weekend.
But it's pretty
much constant 24/7.
And it's really just a handful
of high volume customers
that are using a
functionality they
call Timesheets, where
they want to create
1,000 contracts in one go.
And for that, obviously, when
such a timesheet is created,
App Engine automatically scales
up, creates new instances,
and when the timesheet is
fully processed and checked
with all of the minimum
wages and all the payroll
logic that's behind
it, App Engine
automatically scales down.
It's pretty powerful for Tentoo.
Secondly, we use Cloud SQL
as a reliable database.
We had choices of
databases, obviously.
We chose a relational
one, basically,
because we want to do a
lot of complex querying,
and we have pretty
high volume of records,
but not that much that you
would be looking into BigQuery
or Cloud Spanner that wouldn't
make much sense for Tentoo.
All of the contracts and,
basically, all the files
that are exchanged with
customers and the people that
are employed-- so that's
employment contracts,
payslips, invoices-- they're
all stored on Cloud Storage.
So we've built this
application in about a year.
We migrated five years
of data, and now we've
been live for about a month.
And there's half a million
files on Cloud Storage,
obviously without any
degrade of performance
and requiring no
service base on-prem.
There are still some highly
specialized applications
in the on premise network.
One of them is the
payroll engine.
The other is the
accounting software.
And we've built interfaces
with those applications.
It's basically standard
web services as well as
FTP file exchange.
Still pretty old fashioned.
In this project, we've also
moved a really horrible legacy
application to the cloud,
which was basically
trying to do a mix
between customer support
as well as CRM,
which we've covered
with freshdesk and freshsales.
These are both G Suite
recommended applications
as well.
So it's a really nice match.
And we integrate
with them two way--
we built the two way
sync using standard APIs
from those products,
as well as APIs
that we built in App
Engine and choose
to expose for those
specific integrations.
In terms of reporting,
we tend to want
it to have some kind of
BI functionality as well.
So we have evaluated
several platforms.
We looked into
Tableau, which was
quite heavy for the solution
that Tentoo was looking at.
Then on the other hand,
Cloud Data Studio,
also integrated with G Suite,
was a little bit too limited.
So we chose to go for Periscope.
Periscope is a SAS
platform that you just
connect to your database.
You, I think, connect
to the Cloud SQL,
and then you will
be creating nice
looking dashboards that
you can send to people
in a matter of hours, really.
So that's about the architecture
that we're on right now.
So again, we rebuilt the
entire application from scratch
in less than a year,
and we've been live
now for about a month.
We're still in Hypercare,
so still facing some post
go live issues as you always do.
But we use the versioning of
App Engine, actually, for that.
So we push a new version to
production at least once a day.
And then while we
deploy this new version,
we split the traffic between
the internal people of Tentoo,
so that they can run a new
version while customers
are still on the older
production version, which
is like a form of A/B testing.
And as soon as we know that
there are no bugs anymore,
that's actually when we
move all of the traffic
to the latest version.
So that works pretty nicely,
and App Engine as well,
without us being
experts on the subject.
So what's next for Tentoo?
Obviously, we still have
those on-prem applications
that's a payroll engine,
which is pretty sophisticated.
It's an application
running on .NET.
So we're very happy to hear
that, just recently, we're
also able to move that
to Compute Engine.
Secondly, Tentoo is still
using tape, old tape storage,
for their full historical
archive of invoices
and contracts that they want
to move to the Cloud as well.
And lastly, there is
actually a parallel session
going on about Apigee.
Apigee is a platform for
managing and developing APIs.
And given that the new
might tend to run APIs,
we actually want to
consider using Apigee to see
to which degree they are used.
Because some of these high
volume customers from Tentoo
that I mentioned
are actually-- they
have their own IT
infrastructure,
and they actually want to create
the contracts through API.
So we would be using Apigee to
monitor the traffic, as well
as [INAUDIBLE] and the
errors that might occur.
So that was the
most important thing
I wanted to share on how we
use this wonderful technology.
And I'll pass it
back to Dmitriy.
DMITRIY NOVAKOVSKIY: Thanks.
OK, so now, as a matter
of a bit of dessert,
we have one last service
called Cloud Functions.
And Cloud Functions allows
us to deploy the code which
will be executed based on the
event with no infrastructure
involved and, actually, no
even the notion of server
or application involved.
So what this means.
We get the serverless
environments
to build and connect
Cloud Services.
Fully managed execution, so all
the functions that are written,
they execute in
no gs environment.
And you pay per execution time.
So you don't even pay for,
like, constant uptime.
What event driven means.
Event driven means that
you write a function.
Let's imagine that this
is a function that at,
like, the meme subscription to
a picture that was uploaded.
And this function executes
only when some event
within the Cloud happens.
One example is Cloud
pops up message.
So there is a message
in a message queue.
The function triggers
whatever-- these
are symbols what's in the
message-- puts it somewhere.
Cloud Storage event.
The new picture
is being uploaded,
the function runs, adds the
funny signature to the picture.
It should be request
on API endpoints,
or web hook,
something like this.
So again, function runs.
You pay for a couple of seconds.
It goes down.
And also a bunch of
events from Firebase.
So for those of you
familiar with Firebase,
that's the mobile development
platform, which is also now
part of Google Cloud,
which allows us also
to do the triggers
based on analytics,
like certain threshold
of customer behavior
was met with
authentication, customer
has just logged in into
application, and so on,
so forth.
Also around all these products
from different Cloud platforms
which run event
driven functions,
there is now a
movement of frameworks,
of serverless
frameworks, which allow
developers like you to build
fully functional applications
relying fully on Cloud
Functions or similar products
from other platforms.
So no servers at all.
Everything is compute
completely even driven.
I haven't yet actually
seen this in life,
but I would really want to see.
And Cloud Functions
has been recently added
as a support platform
for serverless.com.
That's one of the frameworks
which allow you to do that.
So when is it when
Cloud Functions
would be considered a fit.
So what code would
you put there.
So first of all, something that
is serverless by its nature--
so after you read a bunch of
articles about serverless,
you will realize that
some specific function,
or some bunch of functions,
within your application,
are within the solution
that you are building.
They don't actually
need to constantly run
in backend, middle,
or whatever, they just
need to react to certain
events, like a file was uploaded
somewhere or a message was
received in the message queue.
So same as with Docker.
At some point within your
team, or maybe it was yourself,
you will see that
the people who will
just say, why would we
deploy it on App Engine?
Lets put a function on it, and
let's put the trigger on it
to run whenever the new file
is arriving, like with Eto,
obviously.
So if you need to transform
a bunch of text received
from somewhere, or if you need
to transform even a bigger data
structure, if it's not fit
for Hadoop or Dataflow,
you might as well do
it with Cloud Function
with minimal spending.
Lightweight API
endpoints and web hooks.
As I mentioned earlier, so Cloud
Function-- when you deploy it,
it can be triggered by, for
example, some requests which
it received on a public
a-point and also as sort
of a glue between
the Cloud Services.
So again, instead of writing
some backend engine which
will be sitting there and
listening to the message queue
and then trying to orchestrate
all the other services,
Cloud Functions can
serve this purpose.
So if you need to react to
certain events happening
within your cloud, and if
you want your application
to react and other
Cloud Services to react,
Cloud Functions
is the way it go.
The constraints.
First of all, right
now only single runtime
is available for
Cloud Functions,
so you have to write
them on JavaScript
and execute in managed
no gs environment.
Function a little granularity.
So usually each function
contains only one function.
So they are single
purpose, pretty much,
and must interact via events.
So you cannot call one function
directly from another function.
You have to put the
message into message queue,
and then the other
function will react to it.
OK, so we have 3 and
1/2 minutes left.
So where should I run my code.
You have to choose
the abstraction layer.
You have to consider your
technical requirements.
You have to consider your team.
So is your team ready to
adopt Kubernetes and work
in micro services?
Is your team ready to
conform to App Engine runtime
requirements?
And what is the comfortable
abstraction layer for you?
Do you want to
manage VMs or not?
Technical requirements
move you down the stack.
So if you need access
to GBUs, for example,
for fast processing, or if you
need a specific Linux kernel,
you will have to run
with Compute Engine.
If you want to do Hybrid Cloud
or if you need certain network
protocols, you can stick
with Container Engine
and keep Compute
Engine as abstraction.
If you have the
constraints in terms
of what programming
languages you want to use
and what runtimes
you want to use,
that's the App Engine moment.
Also with team organizations.
So Functions and App
Engine are mostly--
they alert to the teams
that are dev focused.
Container Engine
are the teams which
very well interact with
each other, like dev
teams, ops teams.
And Compute Engine can be
used pretty much for anything.
We've been running
VMs for years.
Come on.
So if at this point, at
the end of the conference,
at the end of the
talk, you find yourself
at sort of a moment of
making a risky decision,
and you're saying, like, OK,
if I move this Compute Engine,
will I be able to live with
it for the next five years,
and so on, we would like to
tell you, don't be worried.
Because most of the customers,
and most of the large scale
deployments, are actually
using a combination.
So nobody, never,
will restrict you
from running some stuff
on Cloud Functions.
Even more, most
likely, Cloud Functions
will be like an additional
capability for you towards--
next to Kubernetes cluster
or to Compute Engine.
High performance
stuff, or legacy stuff,
or customized stuff can
run on Compute Engine.
Micro Services can run
on Container Engine.
So find the right fit
for you, based on this,
based on what you read, based
on what we can talk about
after the conference.
And always be sure that you
can migrate between them.
Because again, within
the Google Cloud,
you will use Cloud
Storage for the storage,
Cloud SQL as a database,
or Spanner as a database.
And all of these
services are very nicely
integrated with each other,
so is the case through APIs,
and so on.
So if, at some point, you want
to move your PHP code off App
Engine into Kubernetes, we have
tons of customer experience,
of customer examples who were
actually able to do that.
So too long, didn't read.
Just a quick recap
of everything.
Cloud Functions, event
driven, single purpose.
App Engine, mostly web
facing code and mobile or web
backends, restricted in runtime,
but very easy to manage.
Just code, no operations at all.
Container Engine, modern,
containerized workloads
and Micro Services
architectures, most likely
if you need it, or you are
already talking about it,
or some other people
are talking about it.
Compute Engine, pretty
much everything else.
Lift and shift control
over operating system,
just really like to manage Linux
operating systems [INAUDIBLE]..
So everything that you cannot
see the fit in the other layers
of the stack, we can fit it.
That's it for today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]